zdf heute live herzlich willkommen seit
genau einer woche nun tobt der krieg in
der ukraine und die bilder die uns von
dort tagtäglich erreichen sie verlieren
nichts von ihrem schrecken im gegenteil
ein weiteres mal wird kharkiv
angegriffen die zweitgrößte stadt des
landes da haben wir bilder vorliegen
bomben und granaten treffen gebäude auch
des geheimdienstes und der polizei und
noch weitere städte in der ukraine sind
unter beschuss präsident selensky gibt
sich dennoch weiter kämpferisch spricht
von 6.000 getöteten soldaten russischen
soldaten und sagt russland werde die
ukraine ja niemals einnehmen können
gleichzeitig akzeptiert ist die ukraine
weitere friedensgespräche und mit
russland die an diesem abend stattfinden
sollen nach frieden sieht es aber nicht
aus der zeit dass hier ist die tu mir
westlich von kiew dort schlugen raketen
in ein wohngebiet ein und auch in ein
krankenhaus
aber nicht nur in der ukraine auch in
russland selbst gibt es widerstand gegen
die von präsident putin befohlenen
einmärsche den einmarsch ins nachbarland
doch in einer diktatur wie russland zu
demonstrieren das ist natürlich
gefährlich egal ob auf der straße oder
im netz dennoch es gibt mutige menschen
einen see war schon im hintergrund
insbesondere auch junge menschen die in
russland ihre ablehnung des kriegs
deutlich machen wollen wir sprechen über
dieses thema heute mit der russland
expertin sabine fischer mit unserem
korrespondenten christiansen in moskau
und mit einem dieser mutigen jungen
menschen von denen gerade die rede war
und das ist der student daniel dawydenko
21 jahre alt der in moskau studiert
einen schönen guten abend daniel
schönen guten abend wir haben kleinere
zeitverzögerung damit müssen wir jetzt
rechnen sie haben in moskau gegen den
krieg protestiert sie wurden dabei
festgenommen sind inzwischen wieder auf
freiem fuß wie haben sie diese ganze
situation erlebt
nova büro erstens wollte ich sagen dass
heute um 19 uhr wieder ein demo hatten
ich bin gerade zurückgekommen und gott
sei dank bin ich frei ich wurde nicht
festgenommen natürlich wie auch alle
normalen menschen bin ich gegen den
krieg denn es man kann sich nicht im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert vorstellen
dass sich zwei so nahe staaten bekriegen
wie die ukraine und russland jeder
ukraine hat verwandte in russland jeder
russe hatte verbannte in der ukraine und
ich glaube
wir sind dermaßen
und wir führen krieg weil eigentlich de
facto möchte keinen einen krieg haben
das ist nur putins krieg und nur er ist
dafür verantwortlich es ist alles
scheußlich und meine ganzen verwandte
meine bekannte und freunde machen jetzt
alles damit man den krieg stoppen damit
man widerstand diesem bösen macht jetzt
sind in den vergangenen tagen mehrere
tausend menschen verhaftet worden sie ja
unter anderem auch dennoch sagen sie sie
waren wieder protestieren was gibt ihnen
die kraft den mut wieder auf
demonstrationen zu gehen
verstehen sie es ist jetzt eine
situation wenn du heute nicht raus gehst
auf die straße dann morgen gibt es diese
straße nicht mehr weil unser staat
wo ist ein
mensch
dermaßen verrückt geworden der zu jeder
in jeder minute auf einen atom knopf
drücken kann und ich verstehe es ist
nicht nur meine zukunft noch sondern
auch die zukunft von allen bürgern auch
von diesen die ihn unterstützen im
moment es ist ein ass alles ist alles
spielt eine rolle die höheren diese
propaganda die sehen diese streitkräfte
habe ich versteh ich du kannst nicht
einfach verängstigt zu hause bleiben
wenn ich jeden tag im internet sehe
diese schrecklichen bilder dass die
menschen die unschuldigen menschen
sterben genau solche menschen wenig die
einfach nur am falschen ort an zu einem
falschen zeitpunkt da waren eigentlich
habe ich auch nichts zu verlieren
im moment deswegen bin ich auf die
straße gegangen und ich werde weiterhin
auf die straße gehen die straße ist das
eine sozusagen die sozialen netzwerke
sind das andere was darf man was diesen
bereich angeht in russland noch darf man
auf facebook instagram twitter und co
den krieg zum beispiel offen kritisieren
verstehen sie
theorie kann man eigentlich alles machen
aber de facto
entscheidet jeder was er macht denn
viele freunde von mir
bei twitter oder bei facebook
sind jetzt im gefängnis die haben nicht
nur eine geldstrafe bekommen sondern
friedlich müssen sie im gefängnis
bleiben viele
menschen die sehen diese risiken arbeite
geben nicht auf und die posten bei
facebook bei twitter bei instagram die
post gegen den krieg und das ist sehr
wichtig weil so
viele leute werden darauf aufmerksam
aufmerksam die noch vor dem krieg sind
deswegen es ist eine sehr wichtige
arbeit noch vielleicht wichtiger als auf
die straße zu gehen ja das ist auch ein
ganz interessanter aspekt wie
informieren sich die menschen derzeit in
russland generell vielleicht wie die
älteren wie die jüngeren welche medien
werden da genutzt
leider
sind menschen die über 50 sind die
schauen sie sich alles im fernsehen an
und dort 24 stunden pro tag läuft die
propaganda das in der ukraine statisten
an der macht sind und in europa gibt es
auch faschisten anderen macht unser ziel
ist natürlich kein krieg sondern
eine spezialoperation damit die ukraine
frei von faschisten bleibt und dass
welche faschisten in einem garten ganz
normalen dürfen wohnen das wissen wir
nicht aber wir werden das bei unserem
fernsehen nicht sehen dass die
zivilisten getötet werden dass die
normalen ukraine leiden das werden sie
bei uns nicht sehen können ich sage
ihnen noch mehr nur heute abend zum
ersten mal in dieser woche hat unser
ministerium bekannt geben dass
irgendjemand von den russen gestorben
sein vorher war keine rede davon vorher
war die rede nur darf und dass kein
einziger russe gestorben ist aber solche
menschen wie ich die benutzten natürlich
telegramm kanal und alle freien medien
kann man nur hier raus ziehen weil
gestern gab es sperrungen von den
letzten zwei unabhängigen medien durch
und erhält deswegen nur telegramm was
noch nicht gesperrt ist damit sehen wir
unsere infos und alle jungen leute
benutzen das unter haben so die
nachrichten ja vielen dank wir werden da
auch noch darauf zu sprechen kommen auf
die sperrungen der medien vielen dank
daniel für den moment wir sprechen
gleich weiter nicht nur in moskau auch
in anderen russischen städten gibt es
proteste wenn auch noch nicht in
riesigen dimensionen muss man sagen aber
klar ist auch der russische staat der
geht mit aller härte dagegen vor
mein name ist niki sagt er normalerweise
erzähle ich euch etwas über russland und
über meinen alltag aber jetzt sind wir
hier um zu sehen was hier passiert niki
zeigt menschen in sankt petersburg die
auf der straße sind gegen den krieg
einige sagt er werden jetzt gerade
festgenommen trotz des risikos lange
haftstrafen protest gegen putin tage
zuvor hatte nicky diese größere
kundgebung gefilmt nein zum krieg rufen
sie in sankt petersburg und
in moskau
proteste die zuletzt offenbar kleiner
wurden wohl kleingehalten wurden auch
durch verhaftungen seit einer woche gut
6400 sagt die russische
menschenrechtsorganisation ovg info
sogar kinder werden festgesetzt dass
sollen diese fotos zeigen die auch die
unabhängige zeitung nowaja gaseta
publizierte fünf mädchen und jungen die
mit ihren eltern und mit
friedensbotschaften zur ukrainischen
botschaft in moskau kamen kinder hinter
gitterstäben
kinder beim polizeiverhör
sie seien aber mittlerweile wieder frei
heißt es noch in haft ist alexej nawalny
der oppositionelle twittert ob du in
russland weißrussland oder sonst wo bist
gehe jeden wochentag um 19 uhr
protestieren
bloß nicht aufgeben auch niki meldet
sich heute wieder nur per mail er habe
keine angst aber er sei besorgt sagt er
und er wolle weiter filmen was um ihn
herum auf der straße geschieht
ja wir haben gerade den telegramm kanal
angesprochen auch von ihnen und das
wollen wir vielleicht gerade uns auch
noch mal anschauen mit unseren usern und
zuschauern zusammen hier also das ist
eine seite ich habe mir das mal
übersetzen lassen das ist auch ein video
das sie dort geteilt haben ich versuche
gerade nochmal abzuspielen
dazu schreiben sie in sankt petersburg
wurden auf einer demo gegen den krieg
bereits einige dutzend menschen
festgenommen rotonda teilt mit das ist
ein oppositioneller verlag aus sankt
petersburg die menschen werden mit
elektroschockern bei der festnahme
geschlagen wie ist das für sie wenn sie
diese bilder ins netz stellen noch mal
die frage befürchten sie repressionen
für sich haben sie da keine angst
natürlich habe ich angst
und heute beim arbeiten habe ich einen
anruf bekommen
vor der polizei und man meinte ich
müsste jetzt festgenommen werden er hat
mir aber vorgeschlagen ist soll zur
polizei abteilung selber gehen was ich
natürlich nicht mache und dann meinte ja
dann werden wir sie auf der straße
aufgreifen und jetzt ich versuche ein
bisschen aufzupassen
ich schaue mich um damit mich die
polizisten nicht sehen natürlich habe
ich angst aber ich verstehe dass ich als
dass die leute in sankt petersburg es
noch schlimmer haben weil die polizei
dort geht viel härter mit den menschen
um sie sind dermaßen brutal des kamins
schlecht mit den worten bezeichnen das
heißt für sankt petersburg wenn man dich
in der polizei geschlagen hat mit
elektroschocker ist das ist eigentlich
gang und gäbe in sankt petersburg gibt
es sogar spezielle deshalb teilungen wo
politisch
gefangenen genommen werden in moskau
gibt es sowas noch nicht aber ich glaube
bald kommt es auch dazu in moskau tja
bedrückenden schilderungen die sie da
uns mitteilen
susanne birck über facebook schreibt uns
ein mutiger junger mann vielen dank dass
du auf die straße gehst und es gibt auch
fragen von unserem publikum und ich rufe
gerne noch mal dazu auf fragen an uns zu
stellen kommentare zu schicken über
youtube die frage von elisa fitterling
was genau passiert mit den verhafteten
demonstranten welche strafen erwarten
diese im normalfall
in der regel
gibt es einen
bestimmten artikel also ich habe für
diese aktion musste ich 10.000 euro
bezahlen maximal kann man 42.000 euro
bezahlen oder man muss irgendwelche
arbeiten verrichten innerhalb von ein
paar monaten ist aber wenn man nicht
festgenommen wird oder festgenommen wird
es ist eigentlich der zufall bestimmt ob
mann festgenommen wird oder nicht aber
man kann auch einen monat oder 15 tage
von dieser verwaltungsstrafe bekommen
in der regel sehr wahrscheinlich ist es
die geldstrafe weil für den stadtstaat
ist es jetzt sehr
wichtig die letzten großen von der
menschheit zu bekommen weil die
verstehen wenn die noch einmal auf die
straße gehen und eine geldstrafe
bekommen wenn sie kein geld mehr haben
um die strafe zu bezahlen auf diese art
und weise werden die menschen gestoppt
noch verstehe weil auch gerade im
beitrag von alexei navalny die rede war
vielleicht noch mal die frage wie gut
ist denn der widerstand gegen putin im
moment eigentlich organisiert denn es
ist ja immer wieder zu hören dass seit
der verhaftung von navalny der
opposition so ein bisschen die
führungsfigur die prominente leitfigur
abhanden gekommen ist weil er ja jemand
ist oder zumindest war der viele
menschen mobilisieren konnte wie sehen
sie diese situation
die absolute ja sie haben
ganz recht nach der verhaftung von der
wald hat haben wir nur einen
oppositionellen einen bekannten der das
ist ilja jaschin der einigermaßen
bekannt ist leider hatten legte dermaßen
charisma tvi
herne wanne damit er die massen hinter
sich ziehen kann deswegen sind diese
proteste einfach nur ein selbstläufer
die menschen bei instagram oder sonstwo
organisieren sich alleine verstehen sie
wenn zwei dreitausend jetzt auf die
straße bekommen dann ist es echt cool
bei einer weile sind 60 70.000
rausgekommen ich weiß noch
2016 waren auch 80.000 jetzt war die
maximale saal 4000
ackeret tono fragt uns haben sie hat er
daniel hoffnung dass genügend menschen
sich den protesten in russland
anschließen um einen unterschied zu
machen könnte putin dadurch tatsächlich
zum aufhören zu einem stopp
was den krieg angeht bewegt werden
lassen sie uns ehrlich sprechen es gibt
keine chance denn
bei uns gibt es eine nationalgarde die
zählen vier
hunderttausende soldaten verstehen sie
und die leute die auf die straße gehen
sind 2000 eigentlich können wir nichts
machen die einzige chance diesen krieg
zu
stoppen sind die sanktionen gegen die
oligarchen wenn sie dermaßen arm werden
dass sie das putin überdrüssig wird dass
sie mit ihm irgendetwas machen kurz um
unsere einzige hoffnung ist bei den
oligarchen die proteste die bringen
nicht aber wir können nicht einfach so
nichts machen ja
daniel wir haben jedenfalls großen
respekt vor ihrem mut wir wünschen dir
alles gute ihnen natürlich auch für die
nächste zeit alles gute und bedanken uns
ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch heute
abend vielen dank dass passierbar waren
vielen dank
ja inzwischen ist moskau international
ziemlich isoliert die sanktionen werden
immer spürbarer und die wenigen noch
verbliebenen unabhängigen
pressevertreter in russland die werden
immer schärfer angegangen gleichzeitig
nennt die regierung ihren angriffskrieg
in den staatsmedien nur
spezialoperationen
nur noch ein rauschen ist zu hören auf
der welle auf der über 30 jahre lang
radio echo moskwy ausgestrahlt wurde der
einzig verbliebene landesweite
rundfunksender dennoch nicht gänzlich
unter kreml kontrolle war in den büros
liegen beruhigungsmittel auf den
schreibtischen
chefredakteur alexej venedig dorf will
vor gericht ziehen zensur sagt er sei
doch laut verfassung verboten
ich bin überrascht immer noch überrascht
nein das hat er absolut niemand erwartet
wir haben auf ein paar unabhängige
medien aber ich glaube sie stehen auch
für den aus
inzwischen ist ein weiteres online
medium blockiert ein weiterer
hörfunksender hat beschlossen seine
sendungen einzustellen weil er so
wörtlich nicht lügen will als regional
zeitungen gestern dieser wahnsinn muss
gestoppt werden auf den titelseiten
brachten wurden sie beschlagnahmt
ich finde das ungeheuerlich das sind
doch die überreste einer freien stimme
die erstickt wurden
wahrscheinlich sagen sie zu viel von dem
was nicht gewünscht wird zensur hat
gestern verhaftete die polizei zwei
mütter und ihre fünf kinder die blumen
niederlegen wollten an der ukrainischen
botschaft sie trugen plakate mit der
aufschrift kein krieg den eltern wird
gedroht die vormundschaft für die kinder
zu entziehen
[Musik]
trotzdem findet der protest der bürger
wege sich auszudrücken
der slogan kein krieg schmückt
inzwischen häuserwände bushaltestellen
balkon geländer und fahrstühle auch wenn
er schnell übermalt wird
und wir bleiben in moskau christian wir
könnten schon hören wir sprechen mit
unserem korrespondenten christiansen ich
habe einen guten abend genau herzlich
willkommen gut dass du bei uns bist wir
haben gerade den beitrag gesehen auch da
wieder bedrückende bilder medien die
dicht gemacht werden kinder die
verhaftet werden wie ist für euch für
westliche journalisten im moment die
arbeit dort vor ort wie sind die
arbeitsbedingungen
also wir können hier so weit noch
arbeiten es herrscht natürlich ein
großer großer unsicherheit auch unter
den journalisten wie geht die situation
weiter wie geht die situation für uns
weiter wie frei können wir noch arbeiten
das hängt dann vor allem auch beim thema
visa und akkreditierungen das könnte in
zukunft zum problem werden es gibt jetzt
schon fälle wo international
internationale medien auf neue
akkreditierung für ihre mitarbeiter
warten denn das ist sehr wichtig und
unerlässlich zum arbeiten ohne diese
akkreditierung kann man sich hier nicht
journalistisch bewegen man kann hier
nicht journalistisch arbeiten
und wenn diese genehmigungen jetzt nicht
kommt für die mitarbeiter dann kriegen
die medien hier zunehmend ein problem
überhaupt berichten zu können wir hören
von neuen friedensverhandlungen am abend
was kannst du uns dazu sagen
russland hatte den ganzen tag da schon
angekündigt dass man eine delegation zur
zweiten runde dieser
friedensverhandlungen schicken würde aus
der ukraine war das den ganzen tag nicht
ganz klar sie ist dann die gespräche
könnten am abend stattfinden jetzt
bestätigte präsident seelands geht das
auch kiew noch mal eine delegation auf
den weg schickt aber die gespräche
werden heute nicht mehr stattfinden die
werden morgen stattfinden und darüber
hinaus würde ich aber nicht zu große
hoffnung auf diese gespräche setzen denn
die maximalforderung gelegen doch so
weit auseinander und die ukraine fühlt
sich erpresst und dass da was zählbares
herauskommt aus den gesprächen kann ich
mir im moment nicht vorstellen obwohl
die russische seite angekündigt dass
auch über das thema waffenstillstand
gesprochen werden soll ganz kurz ein
schub einen richtig lese immer mal
wieder auch ein paar kommentare vor 10
schreibt uns über youtube mit dem
wirtschaftlichen zerfall russlands wird
bald möchtegern star putin geschichte
seinen sanktionen zeigen ihre wirkung da
werden wir später auch noch drauf
eingehen auf diesen aspekt jetzt haben
wir christian gerade die einschätzungen
eines jungen studenten aus moskau gehört
wie würdest du die haltung in der
bevölkerung allgemein eben russland
einschätzen wie viel rückhalt hat der
präsident noch für seinen vormarsch auf
die ukraine
wir haben dann mit dawydenko gehört
gehört zu den mutigen die sich auf die
straße trauen ich fand es interessant
seine motivation zu hören dass er sagt
ich trau mich ich kenne die konsequenzen
ich will versuchen etwas zu bewegen und
im gleichen atemzug sagt er dass es
eigentlich aussichtslos ist dass diese
proteste was bewegen zumindest in der
form insgesamt glaube ich dass es in der
bevölkerung sehr unterschiedlich
verteilt ist wie die menschen informiert
sind es gibt viele die gucken doch noch
das staatsfernsehen wo dann die
propaganda läuft wo ein sehr einseitiges
bild von diesem konflikt auch gezeigt
wird dann gibt es die anderen medien ihr
habt schon angesprochen in der sendung
echo moskwy in und tv doch das waren
jetzt noch zum schluss sender die recht
ausgewogen über diesen konflikt
berichtet haben so wie wir das in
unserer freien medienlandschaft auch
kennen und die haben jetzt massive
probleme bekommen mussten ihre angebote
abschalten und in der bevölkerung ist
eben dieser der informations grad und
was in der ukraine wirklich passiert
sehr unterschiedlich verteilt
daniel dawydenko hat das auch eben noch
mal angesprochen dass er telegramm
benutzt und das da die informationen
kommen aber man muss wirklich sich da
die informationen holen und das machen
nicht alle also das bedeutet dass bei
vielen teilen oder großen teilen der
bevölkerung die propaganda so muss man
es ja fast sagen also das
staatsfernsehen die staatlich gelenkten
medien schon noch verfahren
das kann man auf jeden fall so sagen
sonst würde man das nicht tun man
investiert dann natürlich auch einiges
rein und es verfestigt sich dann ein
bestimmtes bild es wird ja auch ein
bestimmtes bild von der ukraine
gezeichnet als als gefallener staat als
fremdgesteuert staat das wird immer
wieder und immer wieder wiederholt und
ich denke dass das zu einem großteil
noch so wahrgenommen wird und dass es um
das andere bild das komplette bild zu
haben von diesem konflikt dass das bis
dass die breiten massen in russland
erreicht könnte das noch eine zeit lang
dauern eine frage noch über youtube auch
an dich christian an den korrespondenten
merkt man denn die ökonomischen effekte
da haben wir sie wieder schon im alltag
wie kommt das bei euch an
also was wir hier gesehen haben war auch
zu beginn des konflikts wirklich
schlangen an den geldautomaten
die leute haben an den wechselstuben
gesehen die wechselkurse des rubel die
talfahrt des rubel und haben sich
natürlich viele gedanken gemacht wie
geht es jetzt weiter was wird aus der
währung was wird sowieso aus dem land
und haben versucht sich einfach cash
sohlen an den geldautomaten und das hat
auch nicht mehr überall geklappt es gab
manche geldautomaten da gab es dann gar
nichts mehr an anderen eben diese langen
schlangen oder auch nicht die gewünschte
menge die man sonst
an diesen maschinen bekommt und
insgesamt habe ich das gefühl dass bei
einigen so doch langsam
durchschimmert und sich diese angst auch
dass diese angst auch durchsickert was
wird eigentlich in zukunft aus diesem
land was wo in welche richtung
entwickelt sich dieses land und wie geht
es sozusagen die persönliche zukunft
weiter also dass diese sanktionen die er
wirklich massiv sind in allen möglichen
bereichen also im bereich natürlich der
diplomatie in der politik im sport in
der wirtschaft in der musik wir haben
das internationale künstler ihre
tourneen und ihre konzerte in russland
absagen also die menschen werden das im
alltag spüren und viele fragen sich eben
wie es weitergeht und ich habe mit einem
freund gesprochen er ist russe junger
papa geworden und der sagt durch diesen
krieg und was putin jetzt getan hat hat
er die reputation unseres landes für
mindestens die nächsten 20 bis 30 jahre
zerstört und niemand kann uns im moment
helfen
eindrücke aus moskau von unserem
korrespondenten christian selben ganz
herzlichen dank und schönen abend
dankeschön
danke euch auch und wir sprechen mit
sabine fischer sie ist russland expertin
von der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik auch eben einen schönen guten
abend frau fischer
ja es geht um die proteste gegen die
russische regierung gegen den kurs von
wladimir putin sie selbst haben
jahrelang in russland gelebt wie
schätzen sie die erfolgsaussichten des
zivilen widerstands ein
ich denke
dazu im grunde genommen alles gesagt ich
stimme seiner analyse zu
die repression haben vor ausbruch des
krieges schon so zugenommen dass auch
ohne den krieg kaum noch menschen auf
die straße gegangen sind jetzt haben wir
eine noch massivere
repressive situation sind seit ausbruch
des krieges heute haben wir den siebten
tag über 7000 menschen festgenommen
worden
im grunde genommen versucht man wirklich
diesen widerstand im keim zu ersticken
und
die menschen haben einfach angst ja
nicht alle sind so mutig wie der junge
mann dem wir vorhin zu hören durften und
den ich auch unglaublich beeindruckend
fand viele menschen haben auch einfach
er hat selbst gesagt sehr ehrlich er hat
nicht viel zu verlieren er hat
wahrscheinlich keine eigene familie et
cetera aber bei vielen menschen ist das
eben an und insofern kann man im moment
nicht davon ausgehen dass kurzfristig
eine breiter angelegte protestbewegung
entsteht die dann tatsächlich auch
einfluss auf das politische system haben
wird stattdessen werden wir mehr
repressionen sehen und das wurde ja auch
schon in ihrem beitrag gezeigt auch die
repression gegenüber den freien medien
nimmt im moment massiv zu und
journalisten verlassen jetzt auch sehr
eilig das land weil sie sich einfach
einer tatsächlichen bedrohungen
ausgesetzt hören ab wann wäre denn
womöglich für putin ein kritischer punkt
erreicht ab dem er dann von seinem
aggressiven kurs abweichen müsste oder
ist das in seinem denkschema gar nicht
vorhanden
also das ist in seinem denkschema jetzt
mit sicherheit nicht vorhanden und wir
haben es ein bisschen mit einem mit
einem problemen auseinander klaffen
derzeit horizonte zu tun denn
letztendlich müsste putin ja also um der
ukraine die jetzt eben diesem
angriffskrieg ausgesetzt ist zu helfen
um deren situation zu verbessern müsste
putin er kurzfristig davon abgebracht
werden diesen krieg zu führen ich
schließe überhaupt nicht aus dass über
einen längeren zeitraum
die folgen dieses krieges einschließlich
der wirtschaftlichen folgen die sich
natürlich auch auf die elite sehr stark
auswirken würden dass das dann
tatsächlich
innenpolitische veränderungen
sind zeiträume die der ukraine die unter
diesen immensen druck steht jetzt eben
erst mal militärisch nicht helfen wird
also es ist nicht auszuschließen dass
mittelfristig das system tatsächlich
unterminiert wird weil immer mehr
menschen einfach sich abwenden aufgrund
dieser kriegsfolgen aber eben nicht
kurzfristig und letzter satz ich denke
damit ist zu einer solchen zu einem
solchen innenpolitischen wandel kommen
kann müsste im grunde genommen eine
kombination aus gesellschaftlichen
protesten und einer sich verändernden
elite konstellation bestehen also es
müssten sich teile der elite tatsächlich
von wladimir putin abwenden und sich
dann möglicherweise eben auch mit der
gesellschaft solidarisieren und halten
sie die sanktionen dafür ein geeignetes
mittel dass dieser prozess einsetzt
also die sanktionen sind ja erst mal
darauf ausgerichtet diesen russischen
angriffskrieg zu bestrafen und russland
eben
wirtschaftlich und auch politisch
international zu isolieren die folgen
dieser sanktionen habe ich eben schon
gesagt ja können mittelfristig durchaus
solche innenpolitischen veränderungen
bewirken ja aber eben mittelfristig
mittelfristig vielleicht um auch da noch
mal im großen bild zu bleiben weil das
vielleicht auch für alle oder nicht für
sonder mal jeden so ohne weiteres
nachvollziehbar ist und sie gerade auch
schon von den großen linien gesprochen
haben worum geht es ihnen eigentlich
ihrer auffassung nach er spricht immer
davon die ukraine verteidigen zu müssen
er spricht von einer entnazifizierung
das kann er hier bei uns nicht jeder
nachvollziehen wie ist das gemeint
also die rede von der entnazifizierung
ist einfach unerträglich und zynisch er
einfach das gleich vorneweg
letztendlich handelt es sich dabei um
eine rechtfertigung mehr aktiv für eine
politik die darauf ausgerichtet ist zum
einen die ukraine vollständig der
russischen kontrolle zu unterwerfen also
wir haben ja diese kombination aus in
den russischen zielen aus änderungen dem
militarisierung neutralisierung der
ukraine also hier geht es um die
errichtung vollständige kontrolle über
die ukraine als zentrales land in der
russischen nachbarschaft und es geht auf
einer anderen ebene um eine neuordnung
des europäischen
sicherheitssystems im russischen sinne
ja das sind die beiden ziele dieser
aggressiven politik und das macht diese
politik eben auch so unglaublich
gefährlich big ed fragt uns über youtube
wie soll man denn an tut ihnen ran
kommen um ihn vor ein gericht zum
beispiel nach der nach bringen zu können
dieser man sollte seine taten vor der
welt verantworten
das sehe ich genauso
aber tatsächlich ist es so dass ohne in
politische veränderungen das im grunde
genommen
undenkbar ist ja also man kann diesen
präsidenten man kommt an diesem
präsidenten nicht an solange das
politische system stabil bleibt und
letztendlich ist es eine sehr gute frage
weil sie eben genau auch das dilemma
zeigt der putin hat sich in diesem krieg
gegeben und hat diese politik
letztendlich über den point of no return
hinaus verfolgt und jetzt muss er
wirklich fürchten dass wenn er stützen
sollte oder wenn er abtreten müssen
sollte dass er daneben zum beispiel
strafverfolgung ausgesetzt ist oder
schlimmere ist also das macht die
situation im grunde genommen einfach
noch verfahrener weil er sich selbst den
rückweg abgeschnitten hat genau und es
wird ihm klar gewesen sein dass er dann
auch nicht weiter zurück kann denn in
der tat man fragt sich ja sollte es noch
mal zu irgendeiner verhandlungslösung
kommen wie könnte der westen wie könnte
die ukraine jemals mit wladimir putin
wie der ernsthaft verhandeln
also so wie sich die lage jetzt
darstellt ist es außerdem in meinen
augen ein völlig unwahrscheinlich ist
szenario wenn letztendlich also damit
die ukraine mit russland verhandeln
könnte ernsthaft und damit der westen
zum beispiel auch mit russland wieder
ins gespräch kommen oder die sanktionen
aufheben könnte müsste diese gesamte
aggression gegen die ukraine rückgängig
gemacht werden und russland müsste
zurücktreten von seinen
maximalforderungen wir haben eben
darüber gesprochen und
das ist in meinen augen nicht im rahmen
des möglichen
ja also wir werden das mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht sehen
gibt es überhaupt noch in russland
relevante machtfaktoren organischen
eliten militär die sich putin
entgegenstellen könnten weil man hat ja
schon den eindruck dass es ziemlich
einsam um ihn herum ist und er auch in
den letzten jahrzehnten dafür gesorgt
hat dass seine machtfülle eigentlich
stetig angewachsen ist also wer könnte
ihm überhaupt noch in den arm fallen
sozusagen
das ist richtig also es gibt in russland
so genannte machtvertikale das ist die
struktur des politischen systems an
deren spitze eben blasier putin steht
umgeben von einer ganz winzigen gruppe
von männern da ist auch keine frau dabei
übrigen also männern 45 leute maximal
und alles andere in diesem politischen
systemen ordnet sich unter diesem
zentrum an und ist von diesem zentrum
abhängig und zwar sowohl politisch als
auch zum beispiel was wirtschaftliche
umverteilung anbelangt insofern ist es
schwierig absehbar welche eliten teile
zum beispiel sich
abschreiten könnten tatsächlich sind
dies ist die wirtschaftliche elite sind
die sogenannten oligarchen
ja vielleicht die gruppe bei der man das
noch am ehesten erwarten könnte an einem
punkt jetzt in der zukunft die
sicherheitskräfte die sicherheitsdienst
die so genannten ziele wiki werden das
wahrscheinlich nicht sein denn sie sind
jetzt durch diesen krieg noch enger an
vorziehen gebunden als das vorher der
fall war
thorsten befragt und auch über youtube
halten sie es wirklich für sinnvoll das
militär weiter aufzupumpen also gemeint
ist offensichtlich jetzt die bundeswehr
denn man sieht ja dass russland auch
anders aufzuhalten ist als mit
effektiven truppen ist jetzt keine frage
die sich jetzt so speziell aller doch
auch russland schon auch bezieht aber es
geht ja wohl dann in diesem zusammenhang
auch um den gesteigerten italien
deutschland bzw das sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr
naja also erstmal sehen wir ja dass die
sanktionen prozent bislang nicht
aufhalten also das ist eben auch ein
bisschen das problem bei sanktionen und
wir haben es jetzt hier ja mit
wahnsinniger 77 sanktionsrunde sind
wirklich zinslos auch weil sie mit einer
solchen unglaublichen geschwindigkeit in
kraft gesetzt worden sind trotzdem sehen
wir im moment keine verringerung der
kampfhandlungen sondern im gegenteil wir
sehen dass die russische seite ihre
kampfhandlungen
ausweitet und eben auch immer stärker
zivile ziele ins visier nimmt und immer
weniger rücksicht auf die
zivilgesellschaft nimmt also insofern
würde ich sagen sind die sanktionen
kein ersatz auch zb für militärische
mittel leider eher ich bedaure selbst
sehr dass ich das sagen muss aber ich
selbst argumentiere schon länger dass
weil russland sich so entwickelt hat wie
es sich entwickelt hat und die
spannungen in europa vor allen dingen
osteuropa immer stärker zugenommen haben
das abschreckung einfach teil der
politik gegenüber russland und in der
europäischen sicherheitssystem sein muss
und dazu gehört jetzt natürlich auch die
stärkung der bundeswehr dann haben wir
noch eine user frage von holger wehrmann
offenbar ein verwandter ich weiß es
nicht frage was wird passieren wenn die
ukraine erobert werden sollte bleiben
die sanktionen dann bestehen werden sie
noch verschärft gibt es einen neuen
eisernen vorhang wie schätzen sie das
ein
die sanktionen bleiben natürlich
bestehen das ist vollkommen klar vor
allen dingen wenn russland tatsächlich
versuchen sollte die ukraine zu besetzen
würde ich davon ausgehen dass sie
natürlich sogar noch verstärkt werden
ja und da wird man da wird man nichts
davon zurücktreten können ich hatte
gerade den zweiten teil der frage
vergessen entschuldigung ob die
sanktionen bestimmt das hatten sie
beantwortet gibt es einen neuen eisernen
vorhang das verkürzte ich vielleicht
gerade noch mal auch mit meiner frage
meine abschlussfrage sozusagen an sie
was erwarten sie für die nächsten wochen
und monate ich meine das ist immer so
ein bisschen der blick in die glaskugel
aber welches szenario befürchten sie
oder vermuten sie wird eintreten
also dass die frage nach dem eisernen
vorhang ist auch eine gute letztendlich
ist dass das was russland tatsächlich
anstrebt ja also
russland hat ja das russische
außenministerium hat im dezember schon
diese zwei vertragsentwürfe einmal für
die nato einmal für die usa auf
veröffentlicht und wenn man sich die
genau durchliest dann kriegt man eine
sehr klare vorstellung davon was in
welche richtung die russische
außenpolitik da strebt nämlich
tatsächlich in die einteilung europas in
zwei einflusszonen und eine dieser
einflusszonen muss nach russische
vorstellungen eben unter der hegemonie
moskaus stehen ja und das ist im
angenommen eine art eiserner vorhang
konstellation und tatsächlich
werden leider gottes auch in
aussenpolitischen türken in moskau zum
beispiel solche teilung szenarien also
eine teilung der ukraine so schlimm das
klingt aber es wird dort diskutiert was
erwarte ich für die nächsten wochen und
monate nichts gutes leider
ganz viel hängt jetzt davon ab wie
der krieg weiter gehts ja welche kraft
die ukraine und ukrainerinnen haben sich
diese aggression entgegen zu stemmen wie
hoch die kosten für russland sein wird
werden aber ich richte mich in jedem
fall ein auf eine sehr lange phase der
sehr angespannten beziehungen und
instabilität in europa meine ja das
leider können wir nur unterstreichen die
einschätzungen und analysen von sabine
fischer waren dass russland experte von
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
vielen dank für das gespräch
ja und vielen dank natürlich wie immer
auch an euch für eure fragen und
kommentare das war unser stream nach
sieben tagen krieg in der ukraine vielen
dank fürs mitmachen euch noch einen
schönen abend und bis demnächst